to become proficient in most scales it
takes 20 hours to be clear though the
Mastery comes from the next 20. but for
everyone who's intimidated by it it
takes 20 hours to get proficient when I
wanted to learn to build a landing page
like a website I put it off for four
years I got so frustrated one day I was
like I'm gonna [__] learn how to do
this and so I sat down on a Sunday it
took me four hours to build a page and
you spent four years [__] with not
doing it yeah and the thing is it's like
we don't even fear failing We Fear
feeling stupid for me just knowing that
stat in 20 hours I could look at a week
and be like here's four or five hour
trucks I'll learn it I'll become
proficient